google the most beautiful cat in the
world
and the first and most frequent photo
you'll see is of this white-haired
blue-eyed cat i'm rebecca and i'm john
and this is kobe
this all started in 2015. we had only
been dating a few months and i really
wanted a cat started looking online and
fell in love with the british short hair
breed they're just so cute almost
cartoonish looking they're like so round
and expressive and was sort of doing
some research and found a short hair
breeder in the area and immediately fell
in love with a little cross-eyed
adorable kobe online he wasn't named
kobe yet at the time we drove up um it
was in delaware one of his brothers
actually uh caught my eye and i was like
oh look oh look at this cat he's cute
rebecca was like
actually fell asleep in my arms which
was just my heart melted um and i was
like i need i need this cat we always
thought that kobe was so cute when we
first met him as a kitten but as he's
gotten older pretty early on he started
developing this like we call it guyliner
he has these very distinct like outlines
around his nose and his eyes and it just
gives him this like intense beautiful
appearance his
eyes themselves have this almost anime
look to them he like he looks like a
cartoon i always joke he looks fake he
looks like a stuffed animal more
importantly maybe to us from the start
was how great he is loyal and sweet and
in a lot of ways dog-like i mean he
sleeps in my arms every night he is just
like the biggest sweetheart there's also
the sassy side he wears his emotions
kind of on his face he's very vain he
loves to look at himself in the mirror
we suspect that he might actually know
how beautiful he is
the world revolves around kobe so
rebecca started posting pictures of kobe
me in my head i was like you know
rebecca why are you doing that you're
just you know you're just being another
crazy pet owner who's posting pictures
we all have that friend or two or ted
and she kind of told me she's like no no
just don't worry about this she's like
trust me this is gonna be good um this
isn't that i was like okay it's not that
it was kind of that yeah
i mean at the time i thought it was i
think you maybe had some more foresight
into things but never expected that it
was going to take off like it did people
started responding to his pictures the
same way that i was when i first met him
and i was like okay we're on to
something here it's not just us thinking
our cat is the cutest thing ever people
other people are
agreeing
after i posted a few pictures of him
passive instagram nine gags some of
those bigger kind of featuring accounts
started reposting and sharing pictures
of kobe the next thing we know he's on
the front page of reddit and then we saw
that he got this feature on board panda
but all of a sudden we started seeing
all these headlines of is this the most
beautiful cat in the world and this
cat's eyes
better than mine yeah there were all
these like memes going up online we were
seeing him across the internet in people
it was a people magazine and i was like
this is this is crazy the fan art
started coming in as well photoshop
edits of kobe there were nail designs
graffiti
tattoos that people have gotten like
permanent
tattoos on their body of kobe makeup
inspired by him to try to recreate his
iconic eyeliner
incredible portraits and paintings and
anime style cartoons stuffed doll
versions everything you can imagine
people put a lot of time into these
things which to us is even more special
you know this was always just a side
hobby for us but we started hearing from
brands karina nine lives petco starting
with you know cat brands and then other
types of brands started reaching out
spotify with their pet playlist kvd
vegan beauty because of his inspiring
eyeliner seeing kobe on tv talking about
blood donation with a voiceover was the
coolest moment not enough people are
giving blood and giving saves 12 000
lives a day and that was just such an
awesome way to use his account for good
we've made more from kobe than we ever
expected to make in our wildest dreams
we're very unique and fortunate we just
think it's important that he is always
you know benefiting we definitely try to
give him the best life possible and the
best food toys and beds and cat mansions
yeah a tree that you can imagine he is
one spoiled cat
not force him to do anything he doesn't
want to do we really plan our shoots
around him and his schedule and his
moves he has a pretty good you know
obviously
making money and working with brands is
a wonderful part but the better part to
us is the joy that he spreads and how he
cheers people up as far as what's next
for kobe who knows if he's gonna be you
know featured in the james bond movie we
don't know maybe we hope
that would be pretty cool call us yeah
[Music]
you